-We are so lucky to have
Fred Armisen back
with us tonight.
Give it up for Fred right
over there.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And, Fred, I'm always
so taken aback.
You have so many projects.
Not just film,
not just television,
not just music,
but just over a wide breadth
of interests.
And I was just reading in the
trades, as you like to call it,
that you're launching your first
celebrity fragrance.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
And, um, it's more like an --
it's like an ink than --
[ Laughter ]
So, it's like
this ink I'm putting out
that's like
it smells like -- it has like
a very pungent, inky smell.
-Okay. Is it actually ink?
Like is it --
If you got it on yourself,
would it stain like ink?
-It's not about that.
It's about how it smells.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-So, it's got
a very sort of like
inky smell to it
and it's called TheFredArmisen.
-Okay.
-And so you just --
-It's called TheFredArmisen?
-Yeah, as one word.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Why did you choose
to make it one word?
-It was my organization.
They choose it for me, so.
[ Laughter ]
I have like a whole crew
of people
and they come up with all this
stuff and they are so --
-They don't even go to you
for approvals?
-No. They're so talented
and they're so smart.
-Okay.
Do they bully you, Fred?
It seems like they might
bully you a little.
-In their own way,
[ Laughter ]
which is fine. It doesn't --
you know, that's fine with me.
But it's a nighttime fragrance.
And, uh, so you just, you know,
like before you go out,
you just put it on.
[ Laughter ]
-But it doesn't stain like ink?
I want to make sure
because you're doing this
and I feel,
if it stains like ink,
I don't want to put it on.
-It stains like ink,
but it doesn't matter.
[ Laughter ]
-It's really --
-It's the smell.
-It's really exciting.
Give it up for Fred Armisen,
everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]